une excuse moi c'est pas toi qu'on
appelle google non pourquoi
ce qui veut dire en toi je trouve tout
ce que je ressens ce nom est-ce que vous
avez été déjà victime d'une drague voilà
un peu relou elle voudra y ait quelqu'un
et j'ai fait j'ai eu cette phrase
complètement nul à la fin du repas jeudi
alors on boit un dernier verre chez toi
ou chez moi elle m'a répondu pourquoi tu
veux me kane non ah ouais ça s'est
arrêté là isabelle ya un mec silex forme
alors moi j'avais 30 ans j'étais avec ma
soeur elle avait 17 ans il ya un beau
mec c'est disant bien habillé a vraiment
charger jean michel maire non j'ai dit à
ma soeur alors l ebit mais non mais c
était moi c'est à une soirée et c'était
un garçon qui se faisait passer pendant
toute là dedans toute la soirée il est
arrivé tout seul voilà elle se faisait
passer pour un italien
donc il parlait avec un accent à couper
au couteau genre beau gosse italien un
peu comme sanaa et il m'a fait croire
qu'il s'appelait héros parce que c'était
l'époque des vaches en est tout à fait
il ya un petit copain qui rentre dans la
dans la salle qui était absolument au ca
va bull
[Rires]
moi j'ai plein de coude à un mois qui
ont des pizzerias et maîtrise torrent et
genre un bar va là ils sont en cuisine
j'aurais giovanni e à 12 c'est
décourageant mais tu veux mais depuis
que tu t'appelles giovanni est inquiète
pas là c'est pour rester non mr pas avec
satan verte avec ça j'ai un jour qui
malahem véridique qui m'a draguée en
boîte
elle m'a vite fait comprendre comprendre
qu'elle n'accepterait de coucher avec
moi la seule condition c'est que je lui
donne la véritable que quoi que je donne
de votre numéro de portable
un vrai à mon avis ça va donner quoi
donner à huy et celle attendue et au
nord est alors mais je n'avais rien fait
alors éclaté dommage j'ai pas dit ça non
plus je suis amoureux j'aime cuisiner
alors qu'il tombe amoureuse d'un homme
et je voulais les pattes et donc j'ai
fait mon plat fétiche c'est le fils de
feu j'avais fait un truc totalement
stupide en fait il ya un mois j'avais
été dans un quartier à côté avait des
zones pavillonnaires il y avait la meuf
que je kiffe elle avait acheté un petit
chien loup les chiffres lula quitte les
chiens de traîneaux à chiens comme ça
reste qu un jour je passe devant chez
elle et je vois le chien tout seul je
vais prendre le chien et après j'ai eu
une idée de génie
j'ai dit je vais le garder chez moi et
je vais aller la journée d'hier qui a
perdu son chien en fait et je repasse
devant jeudi si ça va bien tranquille
lundi j'ai perdu babybel le ch est
simple et belle vie belle j'avais vu le
sien chez moi j'avais gardé à la fin de
la journée je dis je sais qu'il ya le
chien c'est les mecs d'à côté du
quartier d'à côté j'y vais tout seul je
vais le chercher à spa ouais je ramène
son chien et je suis pas sorti
l'anecdote aller plus loin
c'est un truc de vigne alors évidemment
ça m'arrive beaucoup à et contrairement
à ces gens là se taper à 30 ans mais la
semaine dernière un garçon extrêmement
bon qu'est venu vers moi c'est qu'au car
il s'appelait oui une excuse moi c'est
pas toi qu'on appelle google
non pourquoi ce qui veut dire en toi je
trouve tout ce que je ressens ce nom il
est connecté le gard les ringards de
l'époque je suis très énervé après ton
papa fenway c'est pourquoi enfin jeu
qu'il a pris toutes les étoiles qui
avait dans le ciel pour les mettre dans
tes sujets il y avait aussi les gros on
regarde et valérie j'ai écrites ou non
sur un arbre un bûcheron la coupe et
j'ai écrites ou non sur le sable la mer
l'a emporté j'écris ton nom sur mon
coeur il y rester lemon way vous êtes
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]